[Música]
Hola Esto es África siete días el
magazine donde les presentamos la
actualidad del continente africano Mi
nombre es amal benofman Y estos son los
titulares la vicepresidenta de Estados
Unidos está en el continente africano
kamala haris realiza una visita a tres
países para tratar de estrechar Los
lazos entre Washington y el continente
en medio de las crecientes rivalidades
con otras potencias como China y Rusia
en Ruanda Polo Rusia está libre el
hombre cuya historia inspiró la película
de Hollywood hotel Ruanda había sido
condenado a 25 años de prisión por
terrorismo en 2021 Rusia Sabana se rimó
opositor al presidente Paul kagame
vivirá en Estados Unidos país que le dio
un permiso de residencia permanente el
parlamento ugandés aprobó una ley que
penaliza a quien se identifique como
lgbtiq más se trata de una de las leyes
más represivas del mundo según las ongs
de Derechos Humanos el texto endurece
aún más las penas en un país donde la
homosexualidad ya estaba prohibida
tenemos informe
fue en acra capital de ghana donde
kamala Harris inició su gira por el
continente africano tras el secretario
de estado de Estados Unidos Anthony
blinquen y La primera dama Gil biden es
ahora la vicepresidenta estadounidense
que visita África gana tanzania y zambia
este viaje de poco más de una semana
pretende reforzar Los lazos diplomáticos
entre Washington y el continente
estoy aquí para abordar algunas de las
cuestiones en relación con las
colaboraciones entre este continente sus
habitantes y el pueblo de Estados Unidos
y para reforzar el trabajo que
Seguiremos realizando juntos
en concreto en este viaje Me propongo
realizar un trabajo centrado en aumentar
las inversiones aquí en el continente y
facilitar el crecimiento económico y las
oportunidades
tras la Cumbre Estados Unidos África
celebrada el pasado mes de diciembre en
Washington el continente ha recibido las
visitas de varias personalidades
estadounidenses de alto Rango con este
nuevo viaje a la administración de Joe
biden confirma que no tiene intención de
dejar el continente bajo la influencia
de Rusia y China
Harry se enfrentará a una especie de
delicado equilibrio en este viaje gran
parte de las relaciones de Estados
Unidos con África tienen su origen en la
rivalidad entre Estados Unidos y China
China tiene una gran influencia en el
Continente a través de préstamos de
dinero a los países mediante
construcción de grandes proyectos de
infraestructura como carreteras y
ferrocarriles pero al mismo tiempo los
funcionarios estadounidenses no quieren
que los líderes africanos se sientan
atrapados en medio de esta partida de
ajedrez geopolítico entre Estados Unidos
y China quieren que los líderes
africanos sientan que se está tratando
con ellos en sus propios términos
a Esta visita de haris podría seguir
pronto un viaje de Joe biden el
presidente estadounidense había revelado
esta intención en la Cumbre de diciembre
tras más de 900 días en prisión y meses
de negociaciones con entre Estados
Unidos y Ruanda Paul russes abaguina
opositora al presidente ruandés Paul
kagame ha obtenido una libertad
anticipada rusa ballinas se hizo famoso
después de que su historia fuera contada
por Hollywood veamos
su historia dio la vuelta al mundo
Gracias a una película estrenada en 2004
hotel Ruanda contaba la trayectoria del
ruandés Paul russ Sabana miembro de la
etnia hutu y gerente del hotel de las
mil collín en la capital kigali en este
establecimiento acogió y salvó a 1.268
personas de la etnia tutsi durante su
genocidio a mano de los hutus en 1994 Y
aunque el papel de Rusia tal y como el
retrato Hollywood fue embellecido según
algunos supervivientes le valió
notoriedad mundial pero años más tarde
se convirtió en un enemigo del estado en
Ruanda sobre todo por su oposición al
presidente Paul kagame al que acusaba de
autoritarismo y de alimentar un
sentimiento antijutu detenido en 2020 en
gigali en circunstancias poco claras al
bajar de un avión que creía con destino
a burundi fue acusado de terrorismo por
atentados perpetrados por el grupo de
las fuerzas canales de liberación que
dejaron nueve muertos en 2018 y 2019 en
su juicio Rusia sabaguina confirmó su
participación en las fuerzas nacionales
de liberación pero siempre negó
cualquier implicación en sus crímenes no
obstante fue condenado 25 años de
prisión pero hoy tras negociaciones con
Estados Unidos país que catalogaba el
caso como Injusto su pena ha sido
conmutada por el estado ruandés a sus 68
años Paul rusa vagina vuelve a ser libre
bajo ciertas condiciones
aceptó que no iba a ser más política
especialmente política ruandesa que iba
a retirarse y vivir con su familia sus
hijos y sus nietos
su Liberación pone fin a más de dos años
de disputas entre Washington y kigali
seguimos en la región de los grandes
lagos el 22 de marzo el parlamento
ugadez país donde la homosexualidad ya
es ilegal
Tuvo una ley con nuevas y severas
sanciones contra las personas de la
comunidad
lgbtiq más el texto ampliamente
denunciado por las organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos tiene ahora que ser
promulgado por el presidente joely
musevini antes de entrar en vigor este
había calificado a las personas lgbtiq
más con la frase desviados de lo normal
los detalles los trae Marian con él
nuestra corresponsal en la región la
aprobación de esta ley por el parlamento
es el resultado de una Nueva Ola de oreo
anti lgbt que sacude yoganda desde enero
aunque los detalles de la ley son
todavía muy vagos según la versión final
de la legislación las personas se pueden
enfrentar apenas de hasta 10 años de
cárcel por actos considerados como
homosexuales así como a cadena
perpetuado
o incluso a la pena de muerte por
delitos agravados en cuanto el
parlamento aprobó la ONU la ong amnistía
internacional Londres y Washington
pidieron al presidente ugandés yuberi
Muse bení que la rechaza Washington
ameasa con aplicar sanciones económicas
ayudando así se aprueba la ley en 2014
19 y 21 el parlamento aprobó leyes
similares pero el presidente o el
tribunal constitucional impidieron su
aplicación yuganda cuenta con una
estricta legislación contra la
homosexualidad herencia de las leyes
coloniales pero desde su independencia
del reino Unidos y 1962 no ha habido
ningún procesamiento por actos
homosexuales consentidos
vamos ahora a la vecina República
democrática del Congo en la provincia de
quibú Norte en el este del país cerca de
800.000 personas viven en campos de
desplazados a causa de la guerra entre
el ejército congoleño y el grupo armado
m23 una milicia apoyada según la ONU por
Ruanda las condiciones de vida en el
creciente número de campamentos
alrededor de goma la capital provincial
son extremadamente difíciles en
particular para las mujeres que son
Víctimas de violencia sexual
el trauma es profundo la escena
permanece intacta En su memoria a sus 68
años yo huyó de los enfrentamientos
entre el ejército congoleño y el m-23
para refugiarse en este campamento en
bulengo en kibú norte Cuando cuatro
hombres aparecieron en el campamento
ocurrió cuando volví al campamento
durante el día me acerqué al pueblo a
unos metros para vender verduras y sacar
algo de dinero Fue entonces cuando
llegaron uniformados con machetes me
amenazaron de muerte y me violaron todos
historias como estas son habituales en
este campo de más de 100.000 desplazados
esta otra mujer también fue víctima de
una violación grupal los hombres me
destrozaron mientras buscaba Leña para
la cocina ahora voy a buscar leña muy
cerca del campamento no me alejo mucho
tengo miedo pero no tengo opción tengo
que encontrar soluciones para sobrevivir
con mi hijo a estas mujeres les quedan
muchas cicatrices a físicas y
psicológicas últimamente cada acuden a
esta tienda de bulengo en busca de ayuda
esta clínica solo trata casos de
violencia sexual ocultas a la vista las
víctimas pueden confiar en las
enfermeras y recibir primeros auxilios
o plato técnico esta enfermera receta
medicamentos y vacunas para prevenir
infecciones en este conflicto es difícil
cifrar el número de violaciones pero
aquí las consultas aumentan cada día se
atiende a una media de 10 mujeres
viene de habernos con lágrimas y mucha
emoción Así que les escuchamos y les
ayudamos a decirse no no eres tú quien
quería que fuera así y cuando se calman
un poco Pueden decir unas palabras más
porque él quemó desde la apertura de la
clínica en febrero las enfermeras han
escuchado y tratado a más de 200 mujeres
violadas una situación que preocupa a
las organizaciones humanitarias que
temen un fenómeno de masa porque cada
vez son más las mujeres que huyen de los
combates en el este del país
enlazamos ahora el continente africano
con América Latina el yongo es una
música y un baile tradicional llegado a
Brasil de la mano de las personas
esclavizadas de origen bandú Es decir de
Congo y Angola es característico de la
región sureste de Brasil floreció en las
plantaciones de café y de caña de azúcar
como una forma de diversión y al mismo
tiempo de resistencia a la dominación
colonial en 2005 fue declarado
patrimonio cultural de Brasil por el
Instituto del patrimonio histórico y
artístico nacional el siguiente es un
reportaje de Valeria sacone y amiguidara
el yongo es una de las expresiones
artísticas más originales de la herencia
cultural africana en Brasil a donde
llegaron más de 5 millones de esclavos
el Jumbo es una danza y un cántico que
viene de Angola y se remonta a muchos
años atrás
hoy celebramos un encuentro con varios
grupos de yongo del Valle del café es un
enorme placer estar aquí con este grupo
maravilloso de bailarines de jungkook
menos conocido que la capoeira es un
vale profano caracterizado por la
umbigada un movimiento sensual que
aproxima los ombligos
[Música]
al mismo tiempo un sentimiento religioso
impregna todas las representaciones los
bailarines por ejemplo tienen que
bendecir los tambores antes de danzar
el grupo jungkoda nació en esta Favela
situada en el barrio de madureira famoso
por ser la cuna de la Samba carioca
[Música]
[Aplausos]
reencontramos a Delhi en este centro
cultural donde enseñan la danza de sus
ancestros a los más pequeños
Quien comenzó el chongo de aserreña fue
mi abuela bobo María Joana y mi tío
darcy Montero que era su hijo
el deseo de ambos era que
transmitiésemos esa cultura a los niños
para que no muriesen nunca y es lo que
estamos haciendo
[Música]
para conseguirlo tuvieron que romper una
tradición centenaria que admitía solo a
los adultos en las ruedas de danza
El yongo es parte de nuestra
ancestralidad es el momento en que
comunicamos con nuestros antepasados con
las personas que ya pasaron por la
tierra este pequeño memorial rinde
homenaje a las matriarcas del yongo
carioca
resistencia es dural permanecer durante
muchos años y no morir nunca y nunca
es considerado uno de los ritmos que
contribuyeron al nacimiento de la Samba
este grupo está ligado a la escuela de
samba imperio Serrano una de las más
tradicionales de Río de Janeiro ambos
simbolizan la resistencia de la cultura
afro en Brasil
[Música]
así termina esta edición de África 7
días Si desean hacer comentarios o
preguntas envían los en la cuenta de
Twitter que aparece en pantalla Mientras
tanto la actualidad internacional
continúa en France 24